There's a moment
when you're just a fan,
and there's a moment
when you're a filmmaker.
And the one moment can follow
the other by about one minute.
I've been directing films
for almost four decades,
and I've picked up a few
things along the way.
For the first time ever,
I'll share some of the things
that I haven't shared before.
Really, every filmmaker
starts as a fan.
I get my ideas the same place
everybody gets their ideas,
out of your imagination.
I can't emphasize enough
the importance of curiosity.
Every film you've ever watched,
every book you've ever read,
every dream you've ever had--
before you can radiate,
you need to absorb.
It's the creativity
law of thermodynamics.
In this MasterClass, I'm going
to talk about storytelling,
suspense, action,
visual effects, design,
all the things you're
going to need to know.
So I'm going to show
a scene right now,
and then I'll go back
and break it down.
The thing that's important to
remember about "The Terminator"
is that it's a love story.
Their eyes meet
across a crowded room.
It's a love story with shotguns.
My goal with "Avatar"
was to have people dream
with their eyes wide open.
I feel like I'm there.
It looks real.
But it has to be a dream.
When I started out, I was
working as a truck driver.
Didn't have much spare cash.
Certainly couldn't
afford film school.
But all you have to
do is pick up a camera
and start shooting something
with the intention of making
a film, and you're a filmmaker.
And I think it's the
duty of filmmakers
that have been down the a road
ways to turn around and say,
"all right, there's
a landmine over here,
there's a landmine over
here, don't step on it."
So why not share that?
I'm James Cameron, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]